oh I wish I started man start it's a
happy Monday but California's on fire
we know some people so weird
I know but I know what bothers me about
being a dude is situations where I can't
be of any help you be help on Tara yeah
big-time volunteer donate money I'm
shooting all day yeah of course right
and if I donate it yes I do donate money
and I will donate money and I will
continue to donate money the problem is
more than 50 donating to [ __ ] the
United Way or the International Red
Cross which is who's out there right now
no and you can donate to the
firefighters dry County animals calm
which is taking care of animals acting
is a good idea problem is that most that
money goes to running the organization
so though you can donate directly to
because I did yes right out there
yeah IND [ __ ] but you can donate
directly to it it's like LA Fire
Department um some can do Donuts what
they doing that's really one thing I've
done I had $50 that old lady went
homeless I got our house back they did
all I had like to believe that I was I
had to do something I like to me I was
the I was the camp I was the straw that
the one straw that I took off the
condado over the hump and the bad the
camel didn't this backs didn't break
yeah I mean I think that's what it was
there's all sorts of things you do to
donate why don't you say forget your
show and just start working as a if I
was a real man and I wasn't trying to
pay off my way to expensive house I
would I would give an episode oh ma but
I give enough money I give a lot of
money actually every year so okay [ __ ]
that I'm not saying that's not the
reason I brought this up the point is I
don't like feeling helpless really
trying to stop wildfires a little bit
did I look at the glass half full right
now please to least it was Malibu where
the average income is very high so those
people aren't as screwed as if it were
to happen in hotels you know South
Central or a different area yes no like
they can they're gonna be okay
hopefully but I'm saying that it's not
gonna be as bad if it were happened in a
lower income area yeah like Calabasas
like kit like I didn't feel bad for Kim
Kardashian when she was like we're so
scared again now I'm making sure you'd
be fine yeah you're gonna be fine
yeah she's like this is so horrible
still no more we're heads the Beverly
Hills house oh you see no no BS titties
oh yeah and she went oh ho gets home
safe girl yeah I'm safe oh I'm coming
yeah let me hold your house down jump in
this purple portion but my friends up
there my friends up there and he you
know Bob Bob
Mariel met at the airport remember Bob
the guy with the fucked-up Bank oh yeah
yeah we call him the strongest man in
the world yeah
Joe Jack Armstrong all America and he is
up there he's not leaving he lives up
there yep he lives on the top of the
hill and there are fires because Brian
they were there were the flames were 100
feet high and he said he's up there
filling with his bad ankle he filled his
roof he's got a part of his room is flat
filled it with water filled his roof up
with water
so nothing watering down the entire
perimeter well and doing whatever he can
and apparently Laird Hamilton is doing
the same thing they usually say it's a
bad idea the people are like now we'll
beat this why because it surrounds you
and you die yeah well it's too late
there's fire everywhere let's leave now
nope wrong yeah I think people are like
category 5 hurricane now it's not gonna
[ __ ] hi huh look at that [ __ ] look
you'd know that I saw a picture on nine
newsom it's one of the planes dropping
off that red or water and it's right
behind a house it is so it's a good
picture it's [ __ ] ridiculous it shows
you how amazing these pilots are I mean
it's so close to Houston it's like
straight up dumping water on yes
and that red stuff I think it covers
like 80 football fields or something
which apparently isn't enough well they
you know they try 80 football fields
yeah
something crazy look at that [ __ ] and
they were talking to how people are like
you're missing the fire that's not what
that red stuff is what is it it's to
prevent the fire from moving forward
that's why we're doing outside the fire
no fire they put water outside the
fighter put this red dodge okay what is
that red [ __ ] we were in elementary
throw up on the carpet and then the
weird janitor come in put all the
[ __ ] and the red stuff that's hero
killer janitor
what it is it is it no never know maybe
it's throw-up is that red fire try and
drop em plans want safe probably I'll
tell you what they'll they air quality
ain't good right now tanker drops
retardant retardant yeah it probably
pretty toxic but it's bad them so am i
hurting you no it's super toxic fire
you know it's super bad for your lungs
fire all organic though bro it is all
organic but you know it ever you know
what burns in this world everything it's
been including rock well rock melts
specially cars yeah what does it say
won't hurt you
here's what's in it cool a um hey what
feels like it fires on in this studio
its hottest [ __ ] yeah I give off heat
dude cuz I'm all I'm fired up right now
I'm a little fired up about all this
[ __ ] that's going on who do we have on
the show today
I know there are they friends of yours B
or no Oh guests coming on the show um
yeah the guests we have coming on the
show are mo mandel very funny comic
comedy it's lovely wife who happens to
be a dick doctor she's a year all and
colors dick ex but she does surgery on
penises and things like that and the
first question I'm gonna ask her is is
it possible to make my dick smaller
because this thing is a pig's Austen to
carry around imma show her mine go what
do you think well as soon as she comes
in i'ma tell her husband shut your mouth
I was in my pants go she just go like
this she's seen dicks did I ever tell
you the story about me and deciding in
college that I had a small penis nope I
decided I had a I dread a thing about
funguses on dicks one day the side of my
dick started itching and I went I
clearly have a fungus on my dick or
herpes I will now take a brush to it and
this is this is when I think back about
what a [ __ ] I was I said I'm so [ __ ]
appalled
I would scrub my dick finally I went to
the doctor because the side of my dick
was purple it was all purple from
rubbing or just I did this is what the
doctor kept saying when he was looking
at my dick I'm not kidding I won't tell
her he kept going
hey goes
what why go I have a fungus and he looks
at me I don't think that's a fungus what
are you doing and I go I'm scrubbing he
goes so he goes really I go yeah goes
and how long does it go I don't know
like a month he goes really because they
really is he was and that's what you're
doing I said yeah because and that's
what happened to it I go yeah he goes
really and he looks really Gaius I you
don't have anything going on you've been
rubbing this thing I go one why'd you
die go I felt I had a fungus because do
you know what a fungus looks like why
would you have a fungus on your dick to
even know what no but I read a thing is
don't read the ID you think you had a
fungus I read a thing about it so I got
pair of that way now yeah I all summed
up my god my rubbing giving jack and
offer Leslie my buddy died died of
pancreatic cancer right rare thing for
the next two months I was like well I
have pancreatic having psychosomatic
gave a weird thing with him I went to
the DA same doctor and he goes he looks
at me he goes are you here because of
your friend Sam I went well I have to
because you don't have you don't just
get out get out get out of my [ __ ]
office
no dick prompts there not yet anyways
what was that thing then let's go out
the sides your balls I was just rubbing
it down that's probably why I've so much
testosterone is so much [ __ ] energy I
don't care about the fuzz your balls
gonna ask her why my [ __ ] looks like the
end of my index finger and it just sits
dead with a drip and why my ball I don't
know where we go with this lady we're
gonna find out we're gonna find out
about dicks yeah it's all we talk about
Brendon you know isn't it no I know you
have I really don't like kind of well
because you're not imagining oh you're a
dick expert me - I've had one since I
was oh
born but you're not you're not
imaginative I have a lot of questions
and you gonna be privy to those
questions it's gonna be good it should
be good I never been to a oh I have been
to a urologist that was not a time I I
went to one with Claude Renier that's
how much was you broke his dick yes I
went to one with him
I wasn't thought we were a gay couple
you are I thought I had a testicular
cancer my balls hurt [ __ ] my ball hurt
I went to the doctor the doctor said
your testicles are normal why is they
hurting us what are you doing I said
nothing because there is something
you're probably doing what are you doing
I said well
I thought about I go well yes I read
that you're supposed to flush your
lymphatic system by jumping on a
trampoline so I was jumping on a
trampoline I went and bought myself a
little [ __ ] that's embarrassing
I know and my balls took a little you're
weird kid dude man
you're weird I'm a little weird are you
weird yeah so I'm just here where I'm I
I just I said I'll tell all these
stories [ __ ] woman comes up to me
yoga teacher who listen to our podcast
with a very strong British accent please
note something goes how's your um
psoriasis mm-hmm how do you know as I
listen to every single episode of yours
and Joe Rogan like this is [ __ ]
incredible and I like that like walking
out guys are like the psoriasis kid I'm
like hey 20 or big gay out dark I get
that
how about in your show I'm up on stage
big game oh you ki oh I'm like all right
whoo-hoo-hoo [ __ ] hope the one day I
figure out that big a whoa whoa whoa now
bro don't [ __ ] go him like that yeah
you yeah weep love evil you corrected
him I'm a wise owl
dude the fires are up in northern Cali
are way worse than southern County and I
gotta go to Sacramento Friday and
Saturday Jen can you find out clothes
cyber I know those two the fires I had a
shitty wish you'd answer that yeah I
don't know I don't that says no the
necklace is away enough oh you're from
northern Cal yeah mm-hmm how far away is
it cuz it's closer to San Francisco so
Sacramento is a distance away quite a
bit cuz the fires are in what's town
burning down down did you know that
oh yeah petard town dara dice there's a
lot 300 people are missing I know it's
awful 300 P 3 huh no real yeah I think
it's 200 it's so so it's such a shitty
did we cuz I said my form at the
borderline I told you the borderline
that board on grill or the fun there
three times yeah I used to stand up
there because my friend Jason used to
promote a show there and I loved it
there I had such a great show there one
time and I people are great it's a great
bar I'm gonna do a benefit if I can with
my I'll deal with you okay great let's
do say yeah let's do it
definitely
shut down don't know I don't think so
but let's do let's do a hundred percent
brother we'll get our crew and I'd love
to do that
let's get us an hour thirty four away I
won 34 hour 54 okay should be alright
you're fine buddy yeah maybe they want
to escape I had that issue when I turn I
11 I was performing at a show and I was
like I didn't feel like performing and
then I just got up on stage and I was
like I'm gonna be funny tonight I'm
gonna be funny I'm not letting those
[ __ ] those weirdoes last night I was
watching the People's Choice Awards on E
yeah and they're accepting these awards
I thought I as much of a narcissist in
psycho than I am I couldn't do that
right now with everything going on in
California like giving up being like the
art is you know I do this for you shut
the [ __ ] oh what are you talking about
literally people right up the road at
lose feel guilty right no I'm just like
what it's kind of it's like what are you
doing
like you'd maybe reschedule like now
it's not now that the time to accept
Melissa McCarthy accept an award for her
body of work as a comedic actor well
it's like an island that everyone does
the you know you the thoughts and
prayers are with our firefighters all
right donate money that does nothing
donate money
do something you're a hundred percent
right what do you physically do that was
a little bit I just felt I'd stopped
watch I'm like god this is lame yeah now
it's not the time that's always been my
problem with what they help out a lot
too yeah like I've seen the least one
the biggest the midterms with the voting
like Hollywood death my issues a lot of
people with Hollywood like they can
paint a narrative in like with their
followers and you look at a lot of
influential people like they can get
people to do some [ __ ] man but might
here's my problem with Hollywood it's a
super short attention span so for one
Oscars it was gender reassignment
surgery and being transgender was
something that was celebrated and we're
behind you and stuff then it's Oscars to
to white and now it's like me to arrest
me to miss that then it's the me to move
that kind of stuff a but it's super then
it was before that was global warming
and they were everybody's making
speeches so they tend to go from issue
to issue but it's a very short attention
span then we kind of move on give the
you a few seasons yeah
Leo DiCaprio got up accepted his Oscar
for their Simon we talked about global
war dating from Leonardo I mean he might
behind-the-scenes be doing a shill of
stuff we don't know about he's not
cooling the planet but I appreciate that
he might be passionate about it but
maybe he's donating [ __ ] I think he's
donating a shitload of money yeah I'm
sure he's very slated Hollywood can
paint a narrative and get some [ __ ] done
when they want to yeah big time yeah big
time they can write stories about it
that moved people you know what they
just what they're following though like
what was soso what book did Harriet
Beecher snow a little trivia for
everybody Harriet Beecher snow woods
with the question I'm gonna tell you
about how art can change the world
Harriet Beecher Stowe wrote a book
called Uncle Tom Tom's neighbors have
him okay
that's okay there's no reason for you to
know it's not a Ripley I'm not I was
going up you know I knew it was cabin
I'm not a lip reader try it again try it
again and just like but like it's your
idea so Harriet Beecher snow yes he
wrote that book called uncle Uncle Tom's
Cabin right so you know and so it's it
was essentially a book about it put a
human face on slavery on black on black
suffering Ganga better than yeah yeah
well no Harry Beatrice no did it way
back in the eighteen hundreds I think
eighteen something either way what what
President Lincoln said when he met her
was something like you're the little
woman that wrote that little book that
started this huge war or a start began
to started this great war the civil
right because she get well the Civil War
she galvanized public opinion around
that that book in the north to realize
that slavery was afoot now don't you
think it's tougher cuz there's so much
content it's hard for people to find out
what's [ __ ] what's real there's this
show there's that show there's this
narrative like it's tough to write but
what would the book latch on to get
created enough momentum in certain
states with over sure no slavery here
for sure so it's at the time yeah I'm
saying if you write here that morning
now right up but to your point art good
movies good books art artistic
expression can really change public
opinion it can make you will and grace
will and grace is considered one of the
beginning so sort of a big
the first day nights well I'll look at
this come on in mo mandel I think he
brought us a gift sorry the parking was
weird
yeah they it's like I don't know what's
going on what's up man how you doing
brother how you doing good to see you
man do you guys know seen them around
the comi store yeah but we've never like
officially yeah yeah hey don't good
brother
big big hairy thing a lot of hairy yeah
I was talking to Thiele valio today but
I was complaining because I had gotten I
spent $2,000 on back hair removal mm we
got to talk about this yeah podcast
we're on back camera laser back hair
removal and talking yeah weird time it
was not good you know I had been in
relation for five years so I didn't
realize it was bad to have back here cuz
you know when someone loves you they
don't care yeah and then when you're out
with these just regular girls on tinder
they're like to let you know like yeah
there's a problem I'll let you know yeah
like like it don't they you know that's
a no that's a thing hairy guys it's like
guys who are uncircumcised having things
like women love a good for skin and
they're like nope we're good on that
yeah so anyway I spent $2,000 it's my
16th session I was like still not really
work and they're like yeah you might
just not be a candidate for this and
then I told Theo von he goes man
jewishback hairs like climate change I
mean that's what's gonna happen it
started but kind of brilliant words why
that works he used to have that joke
where he'd just go Jews a crock clogging
up the internet not only does he have
that Joel I remember being on a TV show
with him called reality bites back in
2008 and we were this is my was just
getting to know him and he's the show of
us it was uh it was a bunch of unknown
comics Amy Schumer Tiffany Haddish me
Leo
Bert Kreischer bunch of people are no
longer in the business and it was
basically right when the writers strike
happened and Comedy Central basically we
just need something to put on and so it
was like let's just take a bunch of
comedians and put him in crazy
situations cool yeah whose it was fun
and then I'm ever you know it's when
you're just starting out calming you
always trying out jokes on your friends
you know and Theo it's goes me Iron Man
we think of this joke
Jews are clogging up the internet and I
was like so it's a setup right you're
gonna be a punchline comment or just oh
that's the joke now that's it by the way
it works it works great
only Thiel could pull that off and how
do you see edge with something like that
now it's just hilarious how do you how
do you write that and know you've
written a joke like how do you look at
your writing pad and be like sorry this
is done it makes you happen it makes you
laugh yeah but you so you're back here
is just free-flowing now no it's you
know it's it's more like acceptable like
I was in my just got back from Miami
Beach last night and I was walking
around on Miami I was like I'm I'm aware
that I'm hairier than everyone else on
this Beach
you try to okay blow up now in Miami no
no I grew up in Northern California in
the country Miami Brian of all the
[ __ ] City I don't know I thought it
was from Miami know where D where D what
viber you get california israel porneia
vibe for sure Miami never get the come
on we're going in New York James Caan
Godfather vibe here's the doctor
straight mono carbon there are smart
ones in the building let her sit closer
to us you sit I want I want them I want
let's put the woman in the middle
otherwise she'll be left out welcome
tell me I do one Brendon good to see you
dr. winter dr. winter it's great yeah
thank you we're we're to
eleven-year-olds nation we were just
talking about how here your man is he's
so hairy do you mind the hair on his
back I don't mind at all he's way more
bothered by it than attractive men yeah
did you shave it even no no no yeah I
don't do that anymore I mean like Ashley
is wonderful
she's wonderful for my self-esteem you
know with all that so she's very like I
think she's attractive it for me I think
anytime your body starts looking like
your dad's it makes you feel old did you
stay in shape yeah yeah are you I'm like
37 look young man you look younger than
me I'm younger than 37 do you exchanger
the me me at all
Savage we look the same I think so I
wouldn't say me and you look the same no
no come on why well Bryan is probably
the best shape of anyone in this room
Wow
Bryan is on some weird vampire blood or
some [ __ ] hang like a bat whatever he
does Debbie looks like all our dad I'm
an old man yeah I'd say so scent holding
and then chin Seconal well Bryan how do
you think Kirk Asians you can't be he's
87 years old maybe or 22
he's like donnell rawlings I have no
idea [ __ ] you know no idea no one will
ever know I feel like a 51 I've figured
out how to have how to take care of
myself so I feel optimal I will say I'll
give that to myself if they take it easy
yeah sleep and not doing anything too
excessive right so not even exercise I
don't believe in this training like
crazy I work out if I feel sore I'll
take a day off well it's funny I was
showing her one of your stand-up videos
yesterday was one you talk about your
action hero thing I go so notice how he
he in a way of making fun of but
highlighting how gorgeous and in shape
he is yes just sort of planting the
seeds and every woman in the audience
who wants to [ __ ] after the show throw a
nice peacock I know I was talking like I
can't wait to go on that podcast see
that guys like like rippling back
Brendon I've always wanted to be a big
athlete a pro athlete but it never
panned out so it's all it's all
essentially trauma and and exercising
mind well this is what's in store but
guys like Brendon because yeah and I
know I don't know you but I'm just
saying like guys who are in this like
comedy used to be degenerates
losers and now those guys like Brandon
and Joe Rogan who's obviously been
around forever but it's like they're
good-looking they're tough and they're
funny and it's why are you funny yeah I
don't get it
like I grew up like the only Jew in the
tiny redneck town I wasn't I was five
Allah a 5/1 in freshman year of high
school I wrestled at 103 and sucked
and so I didn't knows we were like yeah
I had it good I gotta lay low in high
school and now I'm selling that work
clubs in you what everything I'm like
wow
you guys why is Joe Rogan wake up me
like I'm gonna think of funny thoughts
while I live my first ride a trauma
where's the trial guy's childhood was
did he almost drowned and [ __ ] his
childhood was you you don't have
everybody I know who's worth their salt
as either like fighters athletes
whatever had at least chaos it as
children yeah okay so and longing and
and longing no feeling out of place I
think that's to me is the key to anyone
who is funny is like you have to somehow
at least in my limited view you have to
somehow feel like you're kind of broken
and that sort of like your way of sort
of grappling I don't said that Seinfeld
saying you always have to feel like your
clothes are too big for you or too small
for you right right right I think I
think certainly yeah to be funny I mean
you're why would you it's Harry at door
who wrote the books you want on a
National Book Award and this woman said
um we you she had been a housewife for
35 years before that she were you happy
for 35 years being a housewife and
Harriet door said can you repeat the
question it's because okay were you
happy for 35 years being a housewife and
she said I've never heard of anybody
being happy for 35 years and why would
anybody who is happy write a book as
like a surgeon which couldn't emerge
different more different in comedies the
kind of like terror and
self-recrimination and like all of that
stuff that comics have surgeons
apparently have to like they're
constantly judging themselves by their
abilities tiny little super creepy and
like her job validates her as a person
in the way that comedians also have that
thing ya know though we were just at
this conference of all the other people
who do
sexual dysfunction medicine and a lot of
urologists and like most of the people
who are like high-volume penile surgeons
in the country go to this conference we
were just at yep you know your hair belt
and they're just slicing and dicing like
Benny
ya know I know it's crazy right like the
15 year old version of me would have
never said that like I have to do more
penis surgery you know like like but
that's what I'm comparing myself to so
we're there at that conference and I was
kind of down and out and Mo's like
what's going on you know like it's Miami
it's beautiful you're talking these
great people and I'm like but I'm not
this guy and I haven't done as many
penis surgeries is that guy you know and
and yeah so you're like holding your you
know but but yeah I'm a surgeon I like
it like it was that might be like when I
was at the Montreux Comedy Festival
it's a sad thing for her you know you're
comparing yourself the way so what what
what when you say penis surgery what's
the typical penis surgery so the main
things that I would say this group of
doctors do would be surgeries for four
curved directions which is like totally
a huge thing oh yeah so you mean a guy
who can [ __ ] around a corner you could
totally good so the penis that could but
bends this way yeah why did they wait so
long to do it
well they don't wait that long it's
actually that it's the main age it
starts is in your 50s and 60s so like
know your date just goes let's go to the
sex what it's not the thing that I'm
scared this now just hop a row knees and
Jim I thought I was in the clear don't
know but you can [ __ ] it up like tell
him how this happens cuz now that she's
told me how the sound was like I'm
always worried to enter her unless I'm
like rock hard because if you're at all
soft that's how you [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
you know my buddy broke it's going to
curve dick sure sure so curve deck
called Peyronie's disease they think
it's about one in twenty men that it
happens to and starts like in your fifty
sixties it's like a legit thing you
basically wake up one morning and your
penis is curved like like that's it this
is terrifying it's it's absolutely
terrifying Wow why does it do that
delight why does your body go you know
what yeah yeah so a few things there are
some people who have genetic
predisposition people with like like
Viking blood basically like legit I
don't know why like like
maybe they had those hats with the curve
because no one no one would this sort of
curly Jewish sort of oh yeah is there
any precursors so the other thing we
think is mostly what we call repetitive
micro-trauma or basically you're you're
damn you're hurting your penis by like
kind of like folding it in it's probably
like the classic examples I probably
shouldn't be doing yeah like you
shouldn't like you shouldn't be bending
your penis too much when it's like hard
I don't do that we're talking about like
weird angle I think she means like you
know when you go in like for like the
second or third time that night or maybe
even having a few drinks distracted 51 I
don't know what that is but your first
time yeah that's strange
okay so here's a game we want to play
with yeah these are real fixtures and
you're gonna guess what happened to
these penises and as she will tell you
the real thing okay [ __ ] that's a nut
sack with a he's basically has a turtle
I'm gonna say this about that I think
that's that used to be a vagina and it
was a [ __ ] and now they're trying to
enlarge it
no that's someone who [ __ ] up the
walls of their dick and it's inverted
now so this guy put fillers in a scrotum
for cosmetic reasons but the people put
fillers in their penis also to try and
make it girthier and it's like it can
end up in the wrong spot and then this
happens and you basically get a crazy
reaction yeah it's terrible why is why
do people put fillers in their scrotum I
haven't quite understood it yet there's
just all sorts of like ideas of what
it's erotic know something about Botox
in your nutsack so yeah it was like a
basketball what the [ __ ] is going on you
can't expect a woman to deal with it
with a wrinkly scrotum and my scrotum
looks like it's been through five wars
it's been to all the wars I don't care
about his back hair but he's got a
really smooth scrunch is true very true
and also you're born that way or you
eating crap certainly I'm not invested
in scrote och the $2,000 back here they
get a discount so so so so so that would
be
so one so when you do surgery on a
curved penis yeah oh yeah what are you
doing so few different things you could
take some stitches and basically take it
in the back did the other way right you
got a cut into it yeah so you got to
take the skin off and basically drop all
the skin down so that's like what you
called the gloving it's kind of laughing
yeah remember when they made the TV la
Bamba any service you're peeling the
skin off you peel the skin off and then
you basically tweak it back straight and
then you pull this get it back up what
do you mean you tweaked it back Brian
look this is how I look at the whole
conference this weekend in Miami when I
went with her now I'm sure it's better
I'm just I'm sure just like a tattoo
artist it's better when you're dealing
with a bigger body of work no so like if
a but if you're like Tyra and this would
be funny you're like all right all right
we get it
thank you no that's not good let's not
stereotype but I understand for sure
dude jobs exist for a reason no and
that's a shoot like totally astute point
that like Peyronie's disease what it
does is like makes the penis shorter
narrow or like loss of volume so when
you have to go and tilt it back the
other way what are you doing right
you're kind of making it shorter even
shorter right so to these guys it's like
that's the most devastating thing you
could do yeah it's like make it even
shorter right and I'll tell you these
guys like come in it's not really the
curve it's like this mental thing like
it's changed them can you make a penis
larger that's such a good question the
best thing you can do to make your penis
longer is longer not really girthier but
is where a traction device we're gonna
work make it to where look this [ __ ] up
on this show boy no seriously this is
horrific and I'll tell you all these
guys who get like fat injected in their
cut something way down there and a
tendon they extend it you can't doubt
that's that's true you can that right
that's called the suspensory ligament so
that's like basically what holds your
penis up and you can cut that and kind
of drop it down and you'll be hard it'll
be pointing straight down totally so it
can become like
there's all different ones but yeah
that's that's so this this ad says
sizegenetics would you like an eight
basically nine inch penis the penis
extenders quicker easier more
comfortable and guarantees guarantees
extras or your money man larges the
cavernous bodies in the penis right does
that was right so we will actually and I
don't know like that brand if that
brands a safe brand but I can totally
give you and go unlike safe ones but
there's legitimate medical like
published studies lots of them I'm using
these things what yeah so you can pull
your dong lower I have done works use
[ __ ] dick dong this is like particularly
effective like this is maybe like a
fingernail more right I mean this isn't
gonna give anyone like an inch your
money you can you can you maybe have
like a centimeter or two you might but
these guys I mean to be effective you're
gonna be wearing this thing probably
four to six hours every worth it
dudes would do that I mean I wear I wear
Invisalign so why the [ __ ] wouldn't I
work really fast about the big dick
figure this is subject okay so okay you
know when women women who transition
into men right so this is the
fascinating thing where they found out
what tell them it the thing about how
like they want they want women who turns
to men want giant bin decks yeah they
don't want just like average dicks they
want to go big yeah and they found that
the dicks they were asking for making
work too big to fit into anybody right
so they did a study
yeah and UCSF they did a study and they
compared like the best-selling like
dildos on Amazon right now people are
probably aren't being like skimpy with
like dildos and they compared it to the
average circumference of like a like a
neo phallus right which is when you get
like a penis made yeah yeah and it was
way bigger so women can women women
transition they get an actual synthetic
off limits I they take their thigh meat
or arm we live in 2060 hold on I didn't
know this I didn't like thumbs are so
I'll tell you in this state of
California
you want a bigger thumb take myself wait
so they're going inside the key I figure
my dick is I'll and when the guys shake
it in like this my dick Dwarfs my thumb
by the way not to bribe that's a humble
brag so you take the thigh meat you take
by me you can take the thigh meat and
I'll tell you though when you do the
sign me then it's so girthy that like
six months later you go back and you
liposuction it to make it more narrow
but yeah you can't fit it in anything so
your jig is made of muscle fat mostly
okay but so muscle part of the thigh I
don't have a lot of spin bro yeah the
skin for [ __ ] sake you take this gun
in the femur bone your femur
but you said she died muscle so the skin
there like nerves the fat all that stuff
so you have that hangs out right like
eight months later you could get a
penile prosthesis put in to make it hard
about all the tubing and wiring how do
we figure that out yeah so you make a
new urethra yeah totally well this is
what you do
I don't do it exhausting just oh it's
crazy it's amazing surgery though it's
amazing amazing I'm amazing it's just as
good as no normal people no way there's
for sure like complications and
difficulties but also it's so new just
the urethra so when they pee they pee
out of that same yeah one of the main
reasons why trans women will get a neo
phallus
sorry trans men will get a neo phallus
right is not even to have sex it's so
that they can stand to pee because
identifying yourself as a man like a
huge part of that it's like you're
standing to pee and half the time it's
like it's literally like I want a penis
so I can stand in pee like other men do
right they feel like it's not even about
sex it's like about being a man yeah
right and that's like I think I laugh
about this we're talking about was it
yeah we're tell us podcast we're talking
about I thinks are one of them we're
talking about how shemales how it's like
dudes that want to be girls and then
chin brought him up very quickly for
whatever reason brought them up but like
the biggest cost
well that's oh is that funny so it's
like women of transition men have bigger
[ __ ] than anyone in this room my lady
crazy so baby but you're talking about
people who are like biologic men right
you're trying to biologic the fattest
dick so this is super cool so and I was
telling you about this so you were like
what is that title about so we did it we
submitted a research project to like a
like a major conference about about
trans women porn stars right so late
exactly what you're talking about but
who still have penises and like whether
or not they're like having Edie and
whether or not they're taking pills and
stuff like that's the way to go just
keep though I feel like that - like what
have more options yeah I mean like why
but she said like she said it's a
collage we might be sitting different I
don't do that dude but no they can they
you know we can just tuck it down so so
so there is something now a penis
transplant yes apparently is working
that's given their gift so we want so
you know I don't have you guys how you
guys introduce whatever we do this
podcast the full release okay you know
what so it's basically comedian it's
just you're a urologist I'm gonna be
performing I just plug this to the
Phoenix the kid the house economy this
weekend so the house how many things so
we do this podcast and we were at this
urology converse of the weekend we
wanted to give you guys a gift so this
is just a little this is something you
could share I thank you for the random
the random [ __ ] I don't know if
there's enough bows we want to see me
ass on the way over here and hope it's a
live animal I actually have this only on
loan I gotta I gotta admit but it's very
exclusive done it's a dick in a bottle
you in our med school we had like crazy
stuff and all the crap like a cyclone I
guess legit yeah it's a dick extender
for Brian
so so this is a this is an actual penile
prosthesis is inside of this thing
so right we were saying like you could
have a penile implant put in right to
give you an erection so this is like
actually an FDA approved device inside
of that penis and I can show you how to
use it it's not big enough well you got
a but you want put your let's round that
testicle and you just you bite down on
these piles are terrible alright yeah
it's sort of like those Reebok sneakers
but no-one's jealous when you have with
pumps yeah but so this is the legit
thing that like we were talking about if
you were a trans man you have put it in
or if you're a guy who has IDI that
doesn't respond to treatment you'd have
this put in surgically so like it move
faster but I'm trying because it seems
like this the first time this guy you've
been around there and it does come in
different sizes right so it gets like
fitted to you so this one's like 18
centimeters but you can get long on it
for an extra 50 bucks it'll play the
game of Thrones theme song as it gets
hard
I'm confused so this is an actual like
someone will attach this to their body
so and I we should look it up maybe you
guys could pull up like penile
prosthesis online absolutely buzzing oh
you might have just made a car it's not
the bunny about to but you just got so I
doubt that playboy yeah there we go now
we're getting some you could be pressing
the deflate mechanism at the same time
and that it's not going to feel weird
that I have this Brian did that make you
feel at all like inadequate honey I'm
gonna pretend it's mine this is great
thanks I love having the same with you
my Mo's obviously in the woman we're
gonna roleplay later
look at that um so incredible so there's
a there's a device inside right that
would be what would be implanted and
this is just like a model
just look up like inflatable penile
prosthesis
like that would go in would they would
you cover that in skin or that would
that's what you would have so what you
do like you know if a you know sis sky
right and a guy who is like a penis and
he just has a D then you find the penis
and you open up like the two chambers
and you slide the the device in yes so
there are the chambers in the penis yeah
you have two chambers for your erection
and then you have a third chamber that's
the urethra
hold on I'm sorry I'm in it [ __ ] I was
thinking you put that rubber dick and
sew it on to somebody know the insides
you put that blow up yes button on a
real man scrotum and then he has to fill
it up yes so you would have this like an
internal so it would be like an inner
tube for your penis and by the way it's
not just oh yeah to get this [ __ ]
there's not like dudes with like
diabetes yeah
like young guys like what's the earliest
guy that you've done this the youngest
guy I put this in it was 47 Wow there's
younger than you and was he are there
are your customers happy or at least
satisfied 90% or higher satisfaction can
they feel I feel like can get a little
tricky yeah cuz I feel and they can't
ejaculate Abhi's know the end they can't
that's why they do can actually this is
some we were uh yeah I guess I'm Fox at
worship you can Jack you late they have
this [ __ ] amazing
check us out it's called a okay guys who
are in like wheelchairs they can't get
hard at all yeah they have this like
tongs with vibrators on it and they
could hook it onto the dick and they'll
come without being hard coming and being
hard I know so much about this name I
know absolutely nothing to do with each
other yeah is that crazy so the people
in the wheelchair but don't get the same
euphoria from coming even though they're
not hard if they come yeah so it's
different nerves that you used to have
an erection and to have an orgasm it's
different nerves so you don't have to
have both but you don't realize that
because you've probably spent your whole
entire life happy yeah that's the same
time I did this Comedy Central pilot
that was I was writing on that field
that Theo did and part of it was to like
he was gonna help this guy learn to
relax and we were trying to figure out
how to hook these into some pants so a
guy could be coming well he's in started
out in the public
and we could but so if you have this
like inner tube let's say put in your
penis right the skin feels the same you
orgasm the same you ejaculate the same
so it's really just like hydraulic
support like no I'm just gonna that's
it's hard yeah so it's hard here you can
he's not when you first broke down like
damn they're tying on sewing on these
plastic dicks on two people huh is that
crappy any better that's wild that like
you know a guy who can are can like like
the skin and all that it feels the same
I mean it's it's a well first of all
soldiers that have lost their penis a
huge thing it's very important surgery I
just is I mean whatever you're doing
you're on the forefront of [ __ ] that's
doesn't warrants covered yeah so we were
talking about this on the way over right
cuz like it's like observed veterans
dead today right yeah and like one of
the things that makes me so passionate
about this is like um like I was working
in a VA once and we were doing one of
these surgeries right and a guy who's
like like you know Vietnam vet like had
gone through prostate cancer like
couldn't have intimacy and he was having
this surgery right and the
anesthesiologist looked over the the
drape and was like you know why are my
tax dollars paying for that you know and
it's like no way yeah yeah and I don't
understand or she doesn't understand
whoever it was yeah and it's this like
terrible thing that we think that like
sexual health isn't part of health you
know like crazy yeah it is we identify
so strongly with being able to give
somebody else pleasure and being wanted
yeah you know I mean that's two men
that's that's so important it's almost
everything yeah it just is it's a huge
part of virility it's a huge part of
feeling like a man as usual part of all
that it's crazy that like you know until
what the last 30 years if you couldn't
get hard as a guy like he's got all the
dogs done done deal yeah yeah and we
were saying you know like if you look at
health care spending in the u.s. right
like ninety percent of it is spent in
the last like week of life in an ICU
right so we we care so much about like
fighting infections and keeping people
alive when they have no quality of life
but then like things that are so
important to like feeling whole right
having a
or being like a man or a woman you know
we like we just kind of like stigmatize
what's amazing is that I don't I know
very little about any of this stuff and
because in a way in this country you
can't really it's it's very taboo still
it's still like it's still like a
mystery like did the fact that you have
this thing that this is an option in
surgery I didn't know dude this is
something I learned this week at the
conference guy was tagging along with in
Miami this ship blew my [ __ ] mind so
there is this condition out there called
buried penis and when really obese
people it's so big their penis is legit
disappear and I don't mean like they
have like fat over it the skin somehow
you have explains them somehow goes
inside out to neighborhood yeah and
their dick and it's just and if you lose
all the weight turtlehead
yes detective the medical term is
tournament even if you lose weight you
don't get it back and they have a
shorter jury where they'll have to cut
it out they're doing after reaching with
tongs and literally like retrieve it
like pull it out it's bananas but and
then you have to do like a skin graft
why because the all the skin is so
inflamed from being like trapped inside
out like that that it's like useless
like how do you just I was wondering
about that they didn't say they just
dribble yeah you dribble I mean you
probably just sit down and dribble from
it but no is there a nationality I I
talked to a nurse who was it worked for
a urologist and I've seen Oh 35,000 Cox
yeah yeah and she was she was smoking
and she was kind of a and Jimmy Burke
have said to her who has the and before
he kind of biggest [ __ ] show's biggest
[ __ ] the Greeks if your name ends in O
us you got a huge [ __ ] really those toes
just make it look big yeah they're not
actually not buying that I'm not buying
that either well if the Greeks uh
chanting dicks why do they feel the need
to conquer so much that wasn't they were
making every block every Blankfein I
have is going excuse me yes excuse me
yeah yeah yeah yeah I I can't say that
there's like
one specific group that's like then
what's the bit I mean on average not bad
it's just what you oft often whispered
in my ear just stopped me from weeping
while I see my own back here in the
mirror as we make love right Jews Jews
hedges you ever dear get to the cutting
room table you've got that and you're
like Jesus Christ like it's just a
whopper of a dick oh for sure I mean
unfortunately like they'll be doing it
yeah like there you'll be doing some
surgery there's nothing to do with the
penis like some cancer surgery and
everybody feel like people really
comment on it they take a timeout or
like you know you're just and you're not
like being disrespectful I think it's
just like observational when something
is deception relations gravity where
they are or the taking those Abu Ghraib
type pictures so that with these
surgeries you do have to measure like
internally the penis so you get a sense
like over time like different sizes from
that yeah now the longest one I ever put
in was 27 centimeters and I'm trying to
think we always do it in centimeters so
what would that like how many inches is
that just ten Oh ten point six yeah well
it's a soft soft 11 yeah yeah so when
she goes like we get like you know we
take calls our podcast and we should
give me the number but the 90% of them
are like dudes talking about like size
and stuff like that is such a [ __ ]
fixation what is your guys's podcast
about so it's called the full release
and it's basically like Loveline if dr.
Drew and Adam used to [ __ ] yeah you know
we talk about our own relation then we
take calls give me the number do you
have a memory it's 2 1 3 6 3 1 3 4 6 0
or the 4 release pot of gmail.com and so
we just take questions and like and then
we'll so we'll take medical questions
each week and then we'll just talk about
some random weird [ __ ] like we didn't
episode about how animals [ __ ] and take
the weirdest copulation of animals one
of the weirder ones we found was uh the
way bedbugs have sex I'm not sure if
you're familiar
sure of course yeah
to refresh everybody this feels like we
took over that bed bugs do not have
vaginas female bedbugs and the moment I
have sex it is a male bedbug just stabs
the female in the chest with his penis
anywhere and comes and then she gets
pregnant and they the females have
evolved in a way where they don't die
from that
but bedbugs get real frisky in the heat
of moment and I'll often stab other
males in the chest of their dicks and
the male's haven't evolved and they will
die to him so that is running around
with a knife I warn you should never
repress your homosexuality unless you're
a bedbug
okay so [ __ ] kill all my friends yeah
well that's like big guy Brennan comes
and goes I'll [ __ ] it moves everybody my
favorite hazing everybody my favorite
part about this was that so when we were
in Miami he went in did some shows and
afterward some girl came up to him it
was like I love insect sex yeah I was
talking about some tiny ones I was
talking about that on stage and I talked
about like a hemorrhoid situation I'm
dealing with and she came and she's like
you talk about everything I love hearing
about hemorrhoids and in sex acts has
like damage I leave my [ __ ] fan base
hemorrhoids bro I'm dealing with which
nodes an internal hemorrhoid right now
the worst kind not the worst I'm
familiar with myself are you dealing
with internal and external long time we
go amigo okay all right yours is inside
yeah but the weird thing about the
internal ones is there's no nerves once
they get it in there and snap the rubber
band on which that I'm dealing out like
you don't feel anything
they say what did I do they tighten off
the right date it's like the way you
take off a balls testicles the same
thing you just would have rubber band on
you deal with actually no but I do put
my finger up a lot of butts I'm do yeah
to check the prostate exactly yeah in
fact I had this patient once really
recently come in probably like a 65 year
old guy and his 90 year old dad had told
him to find a woman urologist because
our fingers are smaller that dad's a
brilliant really
right cuz I went to old Jewish doctor
with [ __ ] bratwurst to that one of
these he is he out in the valley three
of them in my anus
the problem no dude cuz the guy I go to
unless his name but he looks like a
little Mole and he's got real skies big
thick fingers guy definitely did some
sports
yeah a gold a big athlete huh yeah I got
defensive ends three figures that's a
hero that's crazy
well he's attracted you got doodoo baby
yeah last laugh you know yeah I can't
stand that lowers your copay if you
could make me man that [ __ ] I can't
i-i've had done me I cannot [ __ ]
stand it yeah well you told you get the
[ __ ] in the probably thing I did I was
good though
but starting at 55 you gotta get your
prostate checked I get my prostate
checked now oh you still get oh you can
milk the prostate yeah but I'm not gonna
get my prostate I can't I will say when
I thought I had gonorrhea when I was in
college he stuck a swab in my dick now
you gauging this is some crazy [ __ ]
about my than she has to [ __ ] out of
guys dicks that they put in their own
people stop it up the whole yeah I had
to go into the emergency room I like to
just reach in that bag you'll find some
specialist rotting pipe cleaners you use
there but um this [ __ ] blows my [ __ ]
bar people stick important people like
erotically like putting things out there
does that feel good I don't know I don't
know well Robert Mapplethorpe bring up
that his pictures because they're so
he's got six four of a guy's index
finger stuck right up another guy's dick
and I don't know if you know how painful
that would be but not see what you're
doing here that's why I did I got a
problem with that yeah guide and put I
went to a Robert Mapplethorpe exhibit
with my mom she's a pervert it was it's
just all giant [ __ ] and it was very
uncomfortable
so you're Paul you're pulling things out
of guys I have to take it whoa Daigo
there's a couple of these so go ahead
keep going
so as a urologist one of the things I do
is put a camera up people's urethras
quite financed by the National down in
the arts and catch
huge star people were like I don't want
to pay for this [ __ ]
this is like when red-state people turn
their back the actual photographer he's
got a bullwhip shoved up his [ __ ] he
died of AIDS
now here's the thing Wow gifted artists
prank and it seems like he's the worst
artist but sure man he was part of the
whole baby gags now that's a great
picture now look at the diet look at the
dick coming out of that that guy's
awesome suit and it goes with the suit
it just does now that we have seven
listeners left you so you know what
would you pull out of these penises like
the last thing was a pen but yeah
delicious delicious the thing you
couldn't behind stuff to do this right
online you can buy something yeah so
that it doesn't get traveled up there
right like a butt plug has something so
it doesn't get stuck up to that cord
yeah but it's just so amazing like
people are so [ __ ] warmer guys
basically we're weird
they're weird but like drugs I don't
like people are like that's not enough
now why did you do this and then they
get the point like I just need to put a
staple in my urethra
you're like it knows these crazy [ __ ]
places we were saying I started to a
woman and the or the other day was
saying that they had to surgically
remove a Rogaine bottle from a guy's
rectum oh yeah you want it to work yeah
if you want it to work you got a really
low key the blood stuff I meet some the
butt stuff makes more sense than the
penis shoe yeah yeah yeah I mean I don't
know there there's some like medical
basis for why these things would feel
good like for sure meaning feels good
what's coming out right yes so maybe
guys like just put it back in
yeah yeah because men are explorers
that's why it's held that's how America
was discovered and masters you know
there's like this drive to uncover why
did you stick the penis the pen in your
penis
because it was there there do you guys
get most callers I'm sure looking for
advice on their relation yeah a lot of
like the advice learn you know like sex
addicts and well yeah there's there's
some stuff like that we had a great
couple that we interviewed who is a
swinger couple oh yeah I've actually
banged
jeremy together they said a hedgehog
allah foreign what what aids run germy
now we're kind of current so that's not
great I want to see what that guy looks
like on his girlfriend I mean this guy
well this is chic this guy that was into
that
chuckling stuff that's watching you yeah
what'd you say bizarre kiss to me like
like like course is a sex positive
podcaster there's no judgement where but
that is one where it's just so hard for
me to to get my head around into the
person would be into that like it just
that sounds so weird to me yeah like how
you gain from that
you know so we'll have we had that them
on we had this really fast and this is
actually something that maybe people
ELISA the show are dealing with probably
more so than putting stuff up their
penises these guys we're trying to eat
their wives pregnant and wanting to go
like you know if you're not getting your
wife pregnant yet to go get your
fertility kids right so we have this guy
in the podcast and it was really funny
because it's so funny how people like
think they know about medicine and they
decide to be their own doctor and they
could be completely wrong you know so
we're talking us guys like you know I
had to go in to get the you know I had
to get my my stuff checked to make sure
I'm qualified to be a father so
naturally I didn't masturbate for a
month just to make sure there's a lot of
it in there when I went in there and
Ashley's like you just killed all of
your all of your fertility your body
stops making it really it dies like it's
like it's like milk holding it in ruins
it the sperm quality is the best if you
ejaculate everyday it's a hundred
percent fat so interesting yeah just
because my dear doctor with because with
this fertility thing we're dealing with
he says you got to just don't jack off
three to four days so you'll start more
volume you'll start more volume Satan
doesn't want you to knock your wife open
want some creepy sessions go through
you're right this is like when a
therapist like says your session with
like well I think you're gay all right
next week clearly gay we get into next
anyway let's put you down for 12
sessions and we'll dig into that yeah no
but you'll tell him a little more volume
if you wait a few days but the quality
is the best if you ejaculate every day
do one look at do a lot of I heard that
venereal disease is up especially
chlamydia and gonorrhea
yeah that is true that is you have those
knowing it yeah her son so obviously
people are getting over it on their own
I never know I've played my friend my
friends so funny comic egos have you
ever had a because he doesn't never use
his condoms I go you know you can get
chlamydia gonorrhea goes yeah I don't
know I think I'm immune to that I go he
goes he goes I swear to god he goes you
know is that friend named Brendan Chuck
no I mean I've had a drippy dick but I'm
nothing that's gonna and I go well
that's what that is no I do think it's
well we got it Shane over the last fine
United to fight syphilis but you will
your body will fight gonorrhea chlamydia
eventual did it Al Capone died from
syphilis let me hear the doctor no you
can have for sure real complications
like if you had untreated gonorrhea or
chlamydia you could become infertile
from that right without a doubt in terms
of life as a man for sure definitely but
I mean he's gonna like overwhelm you and
kill you like the way syphilis well no
but it's definitely on the rise all
three of those and versions that are
harder to treat yes and part of this is
linked to prep do you guys know what
prep is no sure don't so so this is
actually kind of [ __ ] crazy that you
don't know what this is because most
people don't but like she's gonna tell
you like it's basically like it's
impossible to spread HIV if somebody
takes prep or if you take it it's it's
basically like HIV birth control so you
take treat what you try to treat HIV
right is antiretroviral drugs so you can
if you don't have HIV you can just take
HIV drugs indefinitely and even if you
have sex with somebody who has HIV
you're not going to get HIV
the gays do it right because if their
man has HIV yeah he's not laughing but
what's so funny is like just how people
like learn the wrong lessons from these
things like we were looking at this
study they did where they wanted to test
the effectiveness right so they got 400
I think was all gay men and Senators go
to take prep and they're like
and so they all took it and they didn't
use condoms they're like none of them
got HIV they disease
yeah to get a lot of that but these [ __ ]
like like like somebody different like
every hour and not ever used condoms
like that was not part of the study
right so an any high-risk group right so
gay men but also other people like sex
workers or you know so so all these
high-risk groups now use prep which has
led to kind of a rear evolution of like
sex right that like safe sex era has
kind of like backpedal yep and now we're
getting all the other [ __ ] and people
aren't realizing it and there's like
becoming like drug-resistant strains of
some of these things and it's like it's
a big deal like we are like the first
time me and Ashley had sex we didn't use
a I mean we've been together for over a
year now so like you know say over a
year yeah not long it's been good it
feels like 10 sure so we we didn't use a
condom and then I do this thing like
damn dawg where I won't use account and
I'll get super neurotic about it and
I'll be like terrified you know so I
made her go down with me to Walgreens
I've done this numerous movie where you
buy the HIV home test it for straight
guys I know it's been slim to vanishing
especially if you're European of
Europeans is that the reason for that
and I don't know if you know this but at
least this is from one there Enriquez
who he's a venture capitalist tonight
but he was taunting TED talk about this
what they found is that if you survive
the bubonic plague which is almost
everybody you know of the European
extraction everybody you know who has
European blood survived the bubonic
plague was killed half of Europe in some
places looking nuts you have a genetic
predisposition there is a gene factor
where where you had you're essentially
HIV resistant meaning that the only way
to get HIV so why didn't HIV become why
was it in African American disease why
was to the East Asian disease and why
was it prevalent in both sexes why in
Africa was devastating to both sexes why
not in Europe had never happened hmm
because you have a genetic
predisposition you're HIV resistant the
only people that actually got it were
why
men who were either shooting up and
getting a shot into their veins or
having or having anal sex and being the
recipient of anal sex the men that were
doing the [ __ ] in the epidemic were
the ones that survived the epidemic so
you made her take the HIV tell Betty's
do as many times she but no one knows
this exists and I actually do a bit
about this in my Santa bag because it's
so funny like this is how little people
use this product and any Walgreens are
Duane Reade or drugstore they sell at an
HIV test or you can find out within 20
minutes just by putting on your gums no
blood to spit if you have HIV but these
are products are so infrequently bought
they're always 50% off my question is
who's walking in there like I think I've
ate that's not marked down [ __ ] it I'll
find out who plus I can't afford you
know baby so I was all terrified and
then I like made her and that's why I
knew she would be a good girl for me
because she could deal with my [ __ ]
your Rosie though I worry about HIV hehe
like dude you know and you bring her
down [ __ ] I would never I'd be like
Matt sorry I know it's not gonna be like
I will be bothered by it for six months
it will just crush the inside I've
called the HIV hotline so many times
road they literally totally like sir you
cannot call here for 48 hours because
worried about Dave I just get like I get
like a neurotic thing am I did you tell
them it's Linda vanishing I know but I
have to deal with this beautiful woman
who comes home having just had her
finger up like a thousand [ __ ] with
germs all over and be like give me a hug
in your [ __ ] scrubs that probably
have a million fob so yeah when he came
home and said that to me I said fine you
have to take one too and you're gonna
pay for it and then we did it it's fine
I was not planning on asking you to
venmo me 50 unless you were positive in
which case I would ask for the day I've
had guys you know like slip up in the
act and then like you have to go spend
50 bucks on a plan B and they're not
chipping in you know which is like in
both people's self-interest yeah like
yeah you guys where'd you guys mean I
was doing stand-up in Portland at a
Harvey's and she had never been to a
stand-up show before so how much she
thought it was hilarious it's actually
you're a funny comic so you you came to
that Harvey's in Portland
it's a good story it's good because so
I'm on stage right and there's this
woman in the crowd very short hair
clearly a lesbian
I would guess and it turned out I was
right taking photos like a giant
telescopic camera like [ __ ] National
Geographic style Karen and I was like
all right yeah it's tough taking
pictures you gotta give me an attitude
about it and she was sitting next to her
and so I noticed I'm like oh this
[ __ ] cute girl you know in Portland
and afterwards I am schmoozing around
you know selling my sweet t-shirts hock
and merch and I see her doing this thing
that only a woman could do and it's not
like and she didn't come up and approach
me she just lurked just sort of like
stood by and if you're a guy doctor lurk
eye doctor lurking dis creeping around
and then so I end up gone with her and
her friend who was this lesbian woman
and she had just moved to Portland and
as were on the the three of us after I'm
like we're talking like this woman like
is trying to [ __ ] you like there's no
world in which she's not trying to have
sex even she was like frat boy lesbian
she's doing his pictures on her phone
like I hooked up with her yeah it's like
it's weird you know she's like
aggressive style fun hang out with yes
she why were you with her did I miss
that the story I'm also not clear about
but so why are we with dating we were
not dating but I was new in town and I
didn't have a lot of friends and I met
her at an Eclipse party through another
friend from New York feel like it was
when the Eclipse thing was going on and
then she was just like doing clips party
yeah well it was like up there you know
it was like right near the totality you
know nothing sounds more Portland than
an Eclipse party
yeah Connect lots of hummus is a huge I
know she was just fun and she drew a lot
of people so then one night she calls me
up and she's like you want to get tacos
and I was like okay and then instead of
going to tacos we go to like an art show
and somewhere else and then most thing
and I was like wasted and then by the
end of the show hungover and that's why
I was just lurking instead of being like
but we we ended up like a lesbian in
[ __ ] block you I had to really maneuver
[ __ ] it's times are thirsty lesbian
man exactly and she was uh it was
whirling lesbo yeah I mean that's
high-level that's how that's high cow
and I had called get beat up to ask them
to come pick us up to go pick me up and
uh and then it was like they're like art
will be there fifty minutes and in that
fifteen minutes like the charm got
strong you know we feel the vibe [ __ ]
did you know I really thought okay
that's gonna happen and then she said to
me was I walk outside you said I don't
know where she got this rituals I'm not
going home with you I'm not a floozy I
said that which is just a homebody
[ __ ] Rosie O'Donnell over here yeah
and then I went home with her me
scissors for the rest it was like this
crazy kiss like movie yeah and while
we're kissing the lesbians glaring us
the club owners staring me the truck
like I think you should pick me up now I
gotta watch your [ __ ] makeup this
girl and it was just like was a
beautiful thing and yeah it was crazy he
he got anything in the cab and then like
this group of like slow clapping yeah
they did and then I walk in the bar like
that was no Chris Farley is asking for
the fries they don't stop
Oh Portland let's go she had aa [ __ ]
flannel come on come over [ __ ] that guy
hard hard she stuck her to the side okay
we didn't have the tacos there's no
[ __ ] honeydicked you with the doctors
she was a cool girl she have a cutoff
shirt I she but she did she said that
guy seems like bad news she said he's a
bad guy
yeah there you go he's a bad guy pay for
a [ __ ] HIV test I get that make her
pay did you when you're when are you
gonna go back to I bet she shows up many
times we have not seen her yet but cool
game she had a lot of game did you guys
get did you get a obereg' share a car
with her back no okay lesbian or no as
me this is just your you know it's like
when your she could've been a Guyana
girl but like I could tell she did he
she was doing whatever a guy would have
been doing a girl trying to be the
friend but she's whatever I guess herpes
a spectrum right you have gay women that
are more masculine in their approach gay
women that are way more feminine
approach and everything in but you know
this is a move every guy's used I've
actually got in a fistfight because of
this scene somebody pulled this move on
come on you know like when I'm also an
incredible fighter an athlete Brian both
we did one of your wrestling that was
great but I you know played one year all
right it was awesome
wait I played hit one year of wrestling
school wrestling fight and I it was like
you know when you're a guide you'd like
give a girl a hug and you and you do
they're like you know you do the hug and
then you kind of try to haul in the hips
and you sort of be like the slope it's a
seal it's there and see if your faces
can can can line up that was kind of
what she was doing conversationally she
was just sort of positioning herself
uh-huh anyway the last fight again and I
remember I seen this guy but an old
girlfriend of mine they were walking out
of this place and I was like
I just don't like the way this guy she's
walking him to her his car they was like
you know partying she was like he was a
friend know what disrupt this guy has so
I said to my friend I'm like let's just
walk out see what happens you know I was
hammered at the time I'm drinking more
but I was drink alot and this guy did
the hug and kind of like slowly did over
and out of nowhere I just blocked inside
in a punishment you thank your girl
who's your girlfriend oh my god blinds
I'm hit a thing that I have like been in
very few fights where I've been
successful usually I don't like drunk
and someone socks me in the face I'm
like well I'm not never do that again
this time I had landed a real punch in
his eye was just like boom yeah it was
just like you fall in a light if you try
to kiss my girl you go understand I you
[ __ ] up and it was like that like
instant like you're gonna throw up
feeling and I just like ran off and then
he emailed me my god my aunt is like a
big-time criminal defense attorney so
email me like I'm gonna go to the cops
all this and my head goes like if he
goes to the cops and says I kissed the
guys girlfriend he punched me in the
face they will just laugh in her regular
kiss other people's people forget the
regular dude it was an article in New
York Times about a guy who said he was a
battered male and his wife hits him a
lot and he went to the cops in here city
good and they they all see he said and
he wrote miracle use and I went in there
and they started laughing and situation
before it wasn't it was no joke I mean
like it I mean like it hurt enough to be
like oh I had to physically violent
girlfriends I didn't go to the cops but
it is a weird thing we're like oh you're
not yeah incapable of causing damage
like that kind of hurt yeah I've
definitely seen men with with issues
because of abusive like women in their
lives and and particularly because you
get like somebody who's emotionally
abusive and then they're controlling you
and then yeah something during like
intimacy or like like we talked about
breaking your penis right like that
person specifically trying to move
during sex to like break no way yeah yes
yeah I'm gonna trying to I finally heard
like a suplex on your dick during sex
like I'm gonna get on top of you and I'm
gonna come down on
Longway if and I'm not saying that's
like a really common thing but I've
definitely heard you know like a woman
can hurt you it's I mean it's not like
you know it's just the dynamic yeah my
buddy broke his dick you was I told to
film it for me because this girl wanted
shot rough and he's an NFL player huge
dude yes seven 260 pounds shredded and
he's like dude this girl wants it so
hard I'm like dude for film that [ __ ] we
were younger and he filmed it and she
would back up he's an NFL player he
would sprint at it oh no oh no no and he
did that and miss the whole of her ass
cheek and his dick when kaku's to the
right we called old doctor sha'ban and I
came in now I go let me see it
and it was like all curved and had these
huge Gregg friends all eggplant yeah and
I went dude this is easy she's gonna
line it back up I'm a walk out you jack
like no Gibson got popped back into
place rushed him to the emergency room
yeah no bleeding I rest in this room
then a dick doctor came in and I was
like he was like lakenya so what exactly
are you doing like well no no come on
girl mm-hmm
oh that's awesome you have to uh when
you do that no you have to start out
like when you take a kid bowling and
they put the little bumpers up dude you
got to put that bumper ups and they
sprint they make sure they fall this
girl's like no he's like I [ __ ] I'm at
the [ __ ] 94 blaster at 94 that's the
most common way term by the way yeah
that's the most common way it happens
sprinting but from coming from behind a
guy a guy coming at a girl from behind
and missing hitting against the the sit
bone there what some other common penis
surgeries that you find yourself doing
okay so the penile prosthesis the curved
curved surgery the curved surgery
there's another kind we didn't talk
about but doing a graft or basically we
can take like a patch of your skin from
your stomach and like patch it down in
there yes that's another one
tell them you said with the meth guy so
if people get their penis strangulated
so like if you leave your penis in like
something for
long in a noose in like if you fall
asleep with a [ __ ] ring and like don't
take it off for way too long like right
yeah so somebody who got their penis
stuck in a soda bottle for a few days
and the coke bottle yeah like a single
serve oh yeah it's not good I mean none
of it is good there's I do the bottle no
yeah but you got to break it around the
[ __ ] and that's a problem how you gonna
break how you gonna break the ring of
what I see possible all right so we have
to they have to come to the emergency
room and basically we have to like use a
like orthopedic bone saw on that stuff
sometimes cuz you want it because right
you don't want to like just hack at it
because then you're gonna like to manual
yeah yeah it's like a dinosaur bone when
you're sort of uncovering gentle very
gentle with with that
Lorraine Bobbitt when she cut off oh
yeah the only way in Bobbitt stick and
they were able to reattach it how do you
do that awesome questions so just like
with the penis transplants it's the same
idea because that's what we call
actually an auto transplant meaning
you're just transplanting something back
on yourself all right it came off come
back on so you hook up right like we're
saying there's the two chambers right
your penis is like three things it's the
two erection chambers and the urethra so
you just make sure to LIKE so the end of
one chamber back to one the end of the
other chamber back to the other and then
you refer back to one right and then
ideally you want to be able to feel the
thing too so you have to find the nerve
and exactly and that's the hardest part
like you can put it back on but the
question is gonna feel like anything
you're gonna attach the nerve the nerve
and the blood vessels because otherwise
if there's no flow there you're also not
gonna get an erection so that's a very
elaborate process oh for sure how do you
do that you pull them out and attach
them worse than our breakdown and how
you do that please do if you're gonna do
like a really amazing job with that
you're either gonna use like a
magnifying glasses like like and you
have to know the dick yes I will allow
her just to sort of inspect my penis
unlike it that makes sense yeah so have
an extracurricular before she goes to
help her ten thousand hours eight
Barry Bonds who's got a batting cages a
lot you know in the statistics this has
been this has been most enlightening
thank you guys thank you guys
well thank you guys for letting us yak
manner how would they do in current
events with us Jenna you whatever you
guys want let's do some current events
current events this type of current
current current topic current events
what do we got oh this is sad
so Stan Lee passed away this morning
Stan Lee had a philosophy behind his
characters you know Stan Lee had a
philosophy behind life Stan Lee was a
genuine real writer there's a difference
there and I think one of the reasons
that those characters stick with us is
they're conflicted and they're real
people they may be superheroes but
they're real rights a spider-man with
great power comes great responsibility
there was always a philosophy behind it
and the philosophy was always pointing
toward good and wasn't I think you were
talking about that I think the reason
the Wolverine was the sort of the first
big hit because why do you know why no
spider-man was no no I'm saying in the
movies Wolverine was such a hit because
it was the first time that a superhero
that killed people
Wolverine killed people yeah most times
we would show expiring they were killed
and yeah well he pushed that guy that's
why they've always struggle with the
Punisher because in the comic books he
was just like I'll just murder people
all the time and they can't ever do that
no did you see the series of Netflix he
[ __ ] dude oh I struggle I struggle
with that one but yeah not to this most
both hardcore fans think Punisher should
be like he should be like a psychopath
like he should be like a guy who was
like murdering everybody yeah yeah those
guys never they never captured the wide
embrace you know there's still the idea
of like super on splatter your honor
you're on it you're on the way if you're
on the side of good which means you
don't behave like your enemy behave
right you don't become them you always
have the higher moral ground and Stan
Lee's characters all have the higher
ground and held to it even when it was
inconvenient it's also it's fine the way
I think what Stanley was so good about
is like or any of the heroes that are
great is find a way to make them all
powerful but also super vulnerable yeah
like there's a reason Superman to the
originals was the best one because he
lost his powers and we could really
relate and add relationship problems
yeah Peter Parker they all dad they
loved they had loves but they couldn't
commit because they had a bigger
responsibility so they were lonely
characters they were lonely
they couldn't ever have a girlfriend but
they wanted one badly Batman's basically
a stand-up comedian right just always
sort of a lone bass we're dudes weird
works at night only only at night you
know these relationships can relax cuz
he's always alone he's a baller The Dark
Knight was just a human it's human he's
not no Batman has no special play right
zero you know his mom and dad mom and
dad died distant growing up probably 77
hours supply from Florida London on his
journey from hell that oh my god yeah so
a British Airways flight got delayed on
its initial day Thursday and it got
delayed on the let's call it the runway
yeah for four hours they had to take
everybody out and they try to
accommodate to everybody by putting them
up in hotels but it was early in the
morning with a big rush they couldn't
get everybody to a room and they were
able to get a new flight on Saturday but
there was something wrong with the plane
so it took them an hour and a half to
get to New York from Orlando they stayed
in New York and they couldn't
accommodate two hotels because the New
York Marathon was happening that same
weekend booked yeah yeah so people were
sleeping in the airport and finally
Saturday they were able to get back to
London I mean if London's home he'd have
to deal with it but I would have just
not [ __ ] sign the cards for me it's
not happening
I hate and there's the thing about like
United or American whenever it's late
I'm always like [ __ ] these guys but
complain to them they'll cool man
yeah there's nothing in do complaining
customer service like very cool man
but if 70 other people want to buy
[ __ ] tonight I got [ __ ] so heated
at Delta today I literally got banned
from Delta for 24 hours you did cuz I
didn't realize is this crazy rule where
if you buy a round-trip ticket and you
don't show up for the first half yeah
they cancel the ticket yes I didn't know
that cuz I feel like I'm giving you a
favor now I'm paying for a seat you know
Lee cancel the whole so I come back a
win it's weird it's a 9/11 thing
whatever reason it's a security I don't
work yet so but they don't warn you that
under that [ __ ] so I had invited a gig
in San Jose and I can't identify up with
a friend and I had my ticket back so I
show up and the guys like alright we're
whatnot you're not on a flight we cancel
em like you didn't tell me that I can't
let go all right let me talk to your
supervisor and the supervisor like
clearly was just like he went in there
he didn't start at zero he came in at 60
so I go all right listen I'll [ __ ]
buy another ticket back I gave my credit
card like he swiped it I go and what's
your name because I want to report you I
think you've been really [ __ ]
disrespectful it goes all right that's
it now you're not taking this ticket
back he takes it back I go all right
we'll get my money bag goes no well I'm
not paying for two tickets I don't use
so we cuz I go call phone cops call
phone cops all right call cops right
here now and the cops show up and he he
stole my cop call like he had made the
cop call so he goes this is why I called
you guys this guys getting out of
control
you know I was like I was like no
officer and you know cops don't [ __ ]
around because I'm like and then the cop
basically takes the other guy goes give
him his money back you are banned from
Delta for the day wow it's like tomorrow
you realize like you get heed these
moments like one false move you're the
guy getting arrested I hope I don't get
mad cuz I know like I don't like I
strayed but like it go to Southwest and
my dude you're [ __ ] an hour and a
half late like yeah we are like it's
[ __ ] up like yeah what are you gonna
do that cable company kind of cockiness
it's like we're gonna go to five United
[ __ ] South whatever you want to do
frontier like it five of us bought my
girlfriend huh you're like cuz I bought
my girlfriend a we would take her to
Europe and I bought
both business classes couldn't afford
first class to that $20,000 business
class seats I don't know how much cost
let's just say this was 12 13 years ago
and I didn't have the money and it cost
me five grand or something a ticket
hours but I'm I got it all lined up and
I got friends in Europe so I had a whole
hour dinner area we're gonna go because
I love this girl she had drug problem
she [ __ ] somebody anyway the point is
and she went back off the wagon started
doing drugs again the point is I broke
up with her give the girl first class oh
no I broke up with her and I and I
[ __ ] I moved out of my house that was
fun I won't go into that but then I
decided you know what I'm gonna get my
money back I'm gonna get my money but
cancel the tickets of course get my
money back and I'm gonna transfer those
to someone else to another girl the guy
goes well you can't do that and I go why
he goes no you you can't the ticket this
is a non-refundable ticket she can use
it though for another trip no [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] so money no it's not
refundable we can transfer it to her I
go I start to free how it is today this
guy this guy this guy goes like this the
guy is so funny how he shut me up
I go give me one reason one reason he
goes I'll give you three numbers I go go
three numbers yeah I'll give you three
he goes nine-one-one
in other words 9/11 yeah I went okay
that makes sense thank you very much and
so she took that ticket she just
canceled it you surveyed Europe there's
insurance now there did you get
impatient it's like $40 H $100 extras
there's insurance where you can do them
she didn't called me and said like
ceremony no I [ __ ] the rugby player yes
so was there more to this breakup cuz
why would she have cheated on you and
still be angry at you I know she was a
drug addict but she was awesome she had
were friends now she was it'd be friends
I wish she's a great person
hello a Dutch man is suing to lower his
age legally and he's trying to argue
that it's the same as changing your
gender
his main reason is because it'll help
him with his job prospects and tinder
he's not lying it will help him and all
that well they I'm Carolyne about your
you know IMDB you know these actors you
know IMDb's like the showbiz website and
it lists people's ages and all these
actors and actually sued them saying you
can't list our ages that [ __ ] up or job
prospects you know everyone lies about
their age in this town and so I'm be won
the lawsuit they're like they're like no
they can say your age you know [ __ ]
age people go down to Mexico I know
actors have gone to Mexico got fake ID
it's like real deal you know [ __ ] I
don't know why them in Mexico but that's
where they got them and so they can
because it's such a currency like it
really is a currency I've never won it
for a pilot one time and with the guy
who created Everybody Loves Raymond and
it was [ __ ] great they asked me 20
years probably thirty three at the time
I killed it you know he's like great
great goes I just said accuracy how old
are you and I said I didn't for some
reason I just didn't lie
and then they feedback of course I got
was he's just you know he's a little old
listen listen I could so I take care of
myself and you know what I get sometimes
people go I gone 51 and they go you look
like you're in your late 40s that's the
most I get yeah so it doesn't matter
well I still look like necessarily
comparable but I understand you 33
you're probably not gonna be able to
play 23 same time you played 28 though
yeah what about no - no the original
Beverly Hills those guys are like
they're late like Dylan McKay and
Branagh these guys were not in high
school I got away for a long time I got
away with playing much younger than that
was for a long time and then father time
comes in and goes we're gonna start
cracking your face up a little bit and
and the Internet any no I I have all
these guys you know like oh oh you're
too young to do this job I cannot
possibly believe you could do this job
and and they're like you must be like 32
it's like you know I'm 34 no but like
yeah I started playing school I don't
know 30 years ago it's not in New Jersey
Rutgers good school I just I'm fine with
it surgeon young because you're nimble
and stuff where I'm not okay with his
psychologist that I've gone to who are
young
I went to one who is younger than me as
like [ __ ] this there's no way your dad
cut you off the gas card last year and
you know where what depressions about
like it's just [ __ ] but a surgeon
you want someone young and nimble well
they also say you want somebody who's
older tubes they've done so many of them
more the thick of this and the problems
with like like changing an ID right is
just not safe like if you come in right
for like health care like I need to know
what your real age is like it's not
about you it's like it's like about
helping you okay yeah like 10 15 sure
but five this guy's heart attack you're
gonna like USB port that I guess not for
if you want for your I'm like Jesus
meanwhile the Grim Reaper's up there
like just so you know I'm sticking with
the original age you're not gonna fool
me with your [ __ ] knows I'm doesn't
care yeah what else you got
he's an exec over at Victoria's Secret
did a interview with vogue say finally
addressing why they don't have any trans
models or plus-size models and his whole
thing was it's a 42 minute long fantasy
show and that people don't have an
interest in seeing plus-size models it's
not lying yeah correct that would be
true be true for for the straight male
versus they're dead everybody bring well
no not for every but a lot of women to
the point is that these are the most
beautiful women in the world they're the
most beaut they're there for it freaks
where we see me go holy [ __ ]
because they're so unique and so
physically beautiful and that's just
what that particular runway is for that
there can be a runway for the other
things but in this case this has always
been the Angels this has always been a
specific kind of aesthetic so just
because it doesn't have room for other
aesthetics doesn't mean it's
discriminatory saying there's no room
for fat angels that is correct but I
think you make sure you make I don't
want to that way Joe no but you make a
good point like this is no one is saying
this is the average woman runway this is
the tough that be like if they're like
hey how come on one guy in the Lakers
doesn't look like Jonah Hill right yeah
there should be one guy who just
dribbles off his foot every time so we
all feel like we belong there
more white guys yeah hasn't liked Sports
Illustrated put like Ashley Graham on
the cover like did people think that
guys think it's hot I do I actually yeah
I think she's gorgeous like she's she's
also I don't she's most healthiest bring
her on her yeah bring up like Isaac but
also guys are probably like like seeing
that meat coming down the Victoria's
Secret you're naming like you met who
was heavy very heavy and she and you
said something she said something to
you're like just can't deal with all the
dick thrown my way and you go no way and
she said just watch right and then after
after the show she was getting yeah yeah
well this is we were talking about this
because we were just in LA and MO and I
were talk about the difference between
the way the binary Miami started the
difference between the way the women are
like showing their bodies their versus
here in my you know yeah it's such a
Latin influence and they're a little
more sexual and open-minded I think it's
so much sexier than the women in LA like
it's why women la don't have those
bodies there's sort of kind of like
puritanical hotness to a lot of the way
women that serve I like the clothes yeah
I don't know I think in Miami the drip
sex that's what I'm saying to see what
your bank you know so Ashley Graham to
me is smokin hot
yeah she's not you know why she's one
ways he's one twinky away from that
let's let's get on the dreadmill yeah
but she's like balancing out which I
find but if you lined her up next to
those Victoria's supermodels yeah and
she taught us out runway everyone like
okay yeah like it's just not let who let
the usher onstage yeah it's like putting
a Prius on that one so so so also the
idea that you know beauty is is socially
learned and stuff I actually
evolutionary biologists and evolutionary
psychologists agree totally not your
science is pretty clear that men prefer
a lot of times I hip to weight ratio of
waist ratio of a certain you know
measurement big eyes full lips that [ __ ]
is delicious and men are drawn to that
and by the way if you have a
disagreement with that you might want to
take a look at how much those women make
on the open market and the reason they
make that much money is because
everybody wants to [ __ ] them also doing
other women by the way well babe
done this I remember in psychology class
in college they they talk about the
study work even babies are built to be
superficial like if you should draw
symmetrical people they're morally yeah
like you really like [ __ ] littles
they come out like little loves little
[ __ ] and nobody wants to hear that
and just ugly people are the ones who
are the loudest like no we need sappy
bond the rod right with this range of
voices
she's hot yes she's hot but it's not
even it's not comparable it's like I can
also drill LeBron James can really
dribble like it's not this there's some
guys who prefer that by the way there
are some guys who prefer I used to watch
comic few in the 90s myself I'm sure
that there are certain ethnicities a
favored a larger what else you guys get
Davidson apologizes for the joke that he
made on SNL by having the Lieutenant Dan
Crenshaw on SNL it was great I love this
I'll play that video that's great
last week I made a joke about a picture
of you and I feel like it would only be
fair if you got me back and made fun of
a picture of me because that's not okay
I don't really need to do that now come
on I deserve alright oh please
first impressions with Lieutenant
Commander Dan Crenshaw thanks Colin this
is Pete Davidson he looks like if the
meth from Breaking Bad was a person it
looks like a troll doll with a tapeworm
that's good we should wrap this up this
is fun this is heat looks like Martin
Short in the Santa Clause one of these
people was actually good on SNL yeah you
got him back the best when his ringtone
went off it was his ex-girlfriend
singing yeah Pete Davidson building in
LA when he first moved here and got
kicked out within a month for smoking
too much weed you know much weed you
gotta have walked out of your apartment
to get kicked out of a building in
Hollywood and then like you know at me
yeah he's a good guy really good and so
funny to a guy yes super town he's one
of those guys we were like wait he's
this young and this successful you want
to be like [ __ ] that guy you're watching
like I get it yeah he's just yeah what
else you got
this one that music teacher I'm sure you
saw the fight already when he was
beating up this kid in class he gets in
a fight Walsh I got this beating first
that's this beating I'll start with that
so this is he's the teacher this is a
student they start scrapping in front of
all the kids so the kids call him bunch
of names racist names he's calling them
the n-word yeah most likely
so it continued to Taunton and then the
strike it's work as a teacher through
first yeah why do you throw first that's
well after a while this [ __ ] [ __ ]
someone said you threw a basketball at
him yeah and the kids being threatening
like what does it feel like I don't know
when you're in my environment all those
[ __ ] feet oh yeah he's getting real
hit but the teachers done I mean he
prefers kids attacking I mean kids are
dangerous so there's a person that works
at the school trying to spread him up
and then he still comes back at the kid
know physically shove me into the wall
yeah this is another Lao this is another
level yeah well it's feel like you're so
man it's like what happened like that so
he did go to jail but then he got he
bailed out and then someone started a
GoFundMe account for him those students
did I think it's like some neighbor or
something like that was it I heard the
other students like there's people there
students there's teachers that took his
side and some people took the kids side
but most yeah everyone says he's a I
don't know if he's fired yet which I got
this GoFundMe account their goal was
$50,000 it's already up to 180 mm I
think they're a bunch of [ __ ] right
by a school right listen all their beat
the [ __ ] has them that the teacher gets
all that money yeah that's 96 years of
being a teacher that's better than most
UFC fighters I don't agree that was
excel no it's not just says thank you
sure he like his life is great with I
wish this video looked like a rap of rap
video just throwing [ __ ] money on
he's got that the PTA he's got the lunch
lady to shaking her tits in his face you
can't physically hit the kids I don't
know no but I'll tell you this is your
story in eighth grade I said to a
teacher he goes you're a bad student and
I said you're a shitty teacher and he
shoved me into the wall I'm from the
class that's
back in the day I told my parents and
they're like you're probably being
obnoxious I would have now is the end of
that it was the end of his nawaz shoving
little different you know I'm saying oh
pretty [ __ ] if you think it is but
still you can't you shove a kid today
you're done you [ __ ] does a kid the
parents are faking a neck injury they
sue the whole [ __ ] school but if
those are two kids reacting right even
if one person was taunting you would
still tell the other kid like you should
have walked away I mean like so why why
this is a grown man
yeah dude come on yes that's a big kid
it's gonna get you so crazy sometimes
like that I mean I don't know we've as a
cheeky physically beat them up I think
everybody has their moment I really do
hope my teachers don't that teach my kid
I hope but I'm also going to teach my
kid not to be like he's been like going
through hard times too you know it's a
tough one you know it's like France they
have immediate like outlawed all cell
phones in all schools like the whole
common like a horror scent that should
be the case because you just think like
I mean and it's great no in France
there's no self like the president in
France made calm yeah it made all cell
phones in all schools totally illegal
that's smart yeah I mean you just think
about what's going on now like I almost
wonder to what extent like all the kids
are videoing some kid goes up in front
he's like acting crazy and you're like
there's these three theatrics too like
what's happening in school yeah yeah
that's funny cuz you make it a point
like if this had happened when we were
in high school the air he said she said
yeah now with cell phones like no you're
guilty like it's a hundred percent but
it's all so [ __ ] up because we didn't
see the context before they start
filming right when they start packing
[ __ ] so did the kid keep taunting
throwing pencils who knows like I had
this chick in high school right thank
you for not breeding on my locker
really just like yeah we just like just
like hated me and disliked this chick I
always just like a sister act like Marcy
go beat the [ __ ] out of this chair
there's a guy you can't do anything in
that regard but that girl deserve have
her ass I'm you cat you can throw down
I feel like cats that looks feisty yeah
caddy cattle [ __ ] punching
like a mijo from Sin City yeah you can
just get my sister to beat up some girls
mow shoes this is pretty fun my younger
sisters did you ever do you ever throw
down your Vietnamese no I have found
that confrontation scares people enough
what else she got chin cat you sent me
this article I did yeah some woman that
drink oh come on pregnant bring in and
uh then this article says then her
newborn went into withdrawal
but that article continues to list how a
lot of babies are being born as attics
because the parents take kratom and they
think it's natural and it's fine but no
so that's before that exciting so he
takes kratom every day I didn't read off
do you know anything about kratom I
don't know enough about it to be honest
but you know that's I mean that's one of
the problems right like something like
that sort of potency usually is like
vetted by the FDA like so extensively
right and it's just not chin things it's
the big concern you know I think it
should be studied but the FDA is taking
that off the table - so anyway so this
argyll came out and so only this is like
the only two cases that they know of
where they felt like this is a
possibility that the the kid is you know
having withdrawals or the dubois having
withdrawals so this woman in particular
was on was on oxycontin oxycodone for
seven years prior right they said yeah
so they said that she like she went to
kratom because of bat and she don't be
oxycodone but let me ask you guys I
would say Creighton but if I was
pregnant I'm not taking him crazy I'm
just like I wouldn't take marijuana or
she's mine for seven years it's that
she's a drug addict yeah she's a drug at
yeah okay should the kratom that's how
powerful kratom Jochen this might take
me from it this [ __ ] took ox Khan for
seven years ago anyway all right I'm
pregnant let's do kratom I'm gonna get
through this like what if the kid comes
out perfectly healthy are you gonna be a
good mom like if you were like if you're
just that just that short wanting no
awards from ya
like you're like six months off being
like a seven year oxycontin like take a
breather first hardcore addict and I'm
sure that's in your body and your system
your everything so it's like part of who
she is now to interject on this though
it's not like it's black or white like
it's not like she had to be an oxy
addict or on kratom right like there's
she could have been enrolled in like an
appropriate rehab program right and
narcotics when used judiciously in
pregnancy are 100% safe i prescribed
oxycodone and percocet to pregnant all
the time really
yes all the time it is it is safe and
effective when it is needs to be used
and like when you choose as prescribed
but what yes yes prescribed oxy for for
pregnant poop I have women as a
urologist women get kidney stones when
they're pregnant all the [ __ ] time
and it's super annoying and painful and
so they're rolling around and you got to
deal with it and it affects a baby
that's such a powerful drug be anything
that's stressful to the mom is hard on
the pregnancy until my I bite down this
piece of wood and fingers will give them
will give them oxycodone a hundred
percent and like we never tell that
woman she is to be in pain for the sake
of her baby because she has to have that
drug right I'm sure everybody in this
room has seen what happens to people
when there are kidney stones it's so
horrifying to have it that's how Jay
lost all the weight my brother had it
and it was the worst pain his life they
started eating healthy she used to drink
all these energy drinks not stopping
sugar and yeah he had one the other day
and he gets him recurrently nobody's the
kind of [ __ ] who's like I just keep
getting I'm like big in changing a diet
is there you go I'll just probably one
next year he's a [ __ ] idiot
my brother says such a painful
experience he off did he have to get the
stent because I know they have to put
this like they put like what is
essentially what like I got a straw just
passed them they hit him with sonic
waves yeah my dad had kidney stones like
the size you you know the end of your
finger I mean it's crazy
yeah what else you got - oh wait so
there's more so the guy that's really
against kratom is the FDA Commissioner
Scott dr. Scott Gottlieb now he probably
have some hidden agenda that I agree
with that yeah so whole hunts she does
the
I found one LT for the babies
who coming out smarter three eyes but
smarter he said they've issued a variety
of warnings on kratom called the report
a tragic case of harm and illustrates
the concerns of FDA has identified about
create including potential for abuse and
addiction right and this is according to
the kratom Institute
no this is the Commissioner FDA he's
also the same guy that last week I
talked about that approved this new drug
DUSU via that's a thousand times
stronger than morphine used for very
important medical procedures and again
but the FDA Commission are the Advisory
Commission warned him against that doing
this as well because it's divert able
yeah no I think I guess John that he's
not cheating in other words kratom we
all know because we did one quick Google
search yeah we know in Thailand we also
know from a lot of people's actual
testimony for some people at least a
very powerfully yeah I got including
Brendan Schaub ten pills yeah I got
whatever the case we know for example as
a caution a lot of other people that we
got hit about that kratom is kind of
addictive so I don't know that he's
being shady I think he might be
responding to the evidence I think
there's a doctor that reports you say
that they've actually identified as
kratom how do you take it like what is
it louder so all it is is a that's try
it and then crush nothing else there
that's the only problem so that that's
why we want to have it like you know
somewhat looked at so we cannot make
sure it's exactly what I like just keep
going then you seem alright this is the
problem when something lives outside of
regulation right you're going to know
that's why so so they have they need to
embrace it because otherwise you're
gonna live at the margin stuck with this
man and like yeah I mean I think that if
they studied it they would probably
figure out how and when and why to take
it and what's gonna be safe and then it
could be integrated but the this [ __ ] is
not a lot of things like this in my life
a lot of things these uppers and stuff
like that uppers I'm telling you what it
what it does have medications it's just
it's that I feel the same on that as I
did taking name another drug the exact
same okay so that's the difference in
man him - I've had a Norco like that
whatever ten milligrams of hydrocodone
I've had your code on and completely
different to me to me this is a really
mild version of that is it possible
doctor that some of people have
different chemistry so we'd a lot of
people like Rogan enough people will
defend we'd to the end and and it's the
thing to do
yeah for me it is it is so ineffective
it just turns me into as um I come
exactly with you what I hear some but
not enough though ever or it becomes or
you're you're comfortably numb and
you're not as productive or you're not
as whatever as you could be if you were
sober but maybe it's good for some
people because they suffer from
crippling has had this the other day so
one of my best friends in college I was
doing the shows of the punch line and he
came to visit and he brought his wife
and I was like I'm so excited for your
wife and Ashley to hang out and right as
we were walking over to me to ask you
better tell his wife just decides to hit
some weed out of a vape pen a slug for
the entire just [ __ ] just for me it
takes me out yeah but you have a great
point it's not just an observation
that's like medical fact that what's
important is a combination of what
you're ingesting and your genetic milieu
to like process things and be affected
by it
right so that's like called a variable
penetrants but basically means it acts
differently in different people highly a
ferryboat including great authors and
great politicians who always had some
alcohol in their system all the time
yeah there are a lot of examples of that
some people just depend handle
whiskey in the morning and yeah super
effective it's just the way it is what I
would love to see though
because I know I definitely agree with
what you're saying to that but what I'm
curious is how long are they able to
continue in their lives that creative
output I would my guess would be the
author's who depend on that to have that
they stop putting out great and they and
they even King talks about it Stephen
King doesn't remember writing two books
Miller he said yeah and he said and he
said even he was sober he was sober
finally yeah hit by a car almost killed
but Stephen King got sober Stephen King
said I don't give credit to my substance
abuse problem for the great books I
wrote he said I happen to have been a
very creative person who also had a
substance abuse problem X totally he
happens to be so [ __ ] creative that
he could drink a case of beer a day at
set and do all the cocaine or whatever
was cheap and still write Cujo and stand
and be able to be a best-seller that's
how my little movie called Shawshank
Redemption I know that one is like an
outlier have you seen all the things
he's he's so pretty
movies crazy yeah thank you I mean he's
done it all but like you like a guy who
I loved growing up was Jack Kerouac like
I know a lot of you know people did and
then you you like you're like read any
of his later works like this is [ __ ]
terrible total [ __ ] home and you realize
like they just the other day now that
wasn't in that one's one of the good
ones like then the road was for its time
I remember my dad saying he was a kid I
just loved on the road and I was like
creative writing majors like I'm gonna
write a great novel I wrote a novel in
college money it's gonna be like my dad
be like he's just drunk
this drunk yeah and then and as an adult
I've been sober about four years now and
I'm not reading like these are all these
are all deep thoughts when you're drunk
what else you guys got no more kratom
chin this particular article
kratom joe mother might not have been
taken creative at all said the doctor
our associate professor Harvard Medical
School it was something that the husband
said she was using so this all these
stories you have to make sure you read
always say there's so many things in
pregnancy you can eat there's just
much fear around pregnancy we've gotten
like we've gone crazy about pregnancy
there's like too much like pregnant mom
shaming like I know women who are
pediatricians who will have a glass of
wine and like not sure like it's just I
don't want to have a good spot because
you have to worry about the bats is she
yeah no Japanese Koreans eat the [ __ ]
out of suits right like he was like
three generations ago what the hell
we're Pratley or smoke smells crazy mom
drinking smoking
I know sure his nose is huge but he
looks fine my mother will tell you pill
can i smoke in your house yes in fact I
prefer it I think it's all [ __ ] go
ahead and smoke yeah when I grew up all
over the world and they all world in
Europe and
they're eating those cheeses like
tobacco is not good for you let's not
know for sure for sure a little a little
of anything is gonna be yeah well that's
fun one yeah sure man all right smile
kratom so pornhub does ease it like
statistics insights and on midterm
elections day it was a funny one it was
up can we say where we got this a guy
who runs a part of pornhub emailed me
said job you guys would dig this use
this on the podcast
check out these statistics I just bought
the name of a porn company that I'm
trying to launch really yeah you trying
to launch your own point oh well a
friend of mine a friend of hers I used a
doctor and now he's friend of mine was
like you know what's always been the
greatest name for a website that no
one's bought raunchy tomatoes dot-com
like rotten tomatoes but raunchy
tomatoes and does like danced hard
before you gon get my have to do you
already know about it you're good yeah I
bucket yeah he was like this right I
want people cuz I was gonna buy it off
me cuz I was like I bought it for 18
bucks I was like see I'm just gonna
launch my own porn side with this so I
did like a day's worth of research I
already felt so horrific it discussed
you know like I can't do this I can't do
this right so my friend goes alright you
buy it though because he didn't his name
so he goes you got to give you 10% I
waited like two weeks and ie my you know
just got an offer for 85 grand
my phone rings oh dude we gotta talk
what world do you think my your initial
offer was 85 grand like the works
negotiator of all that what were these
stats though chin so that the morning of
which is weird the early morning around
like 4 a.m. 5 a.m. it jumped up 20% by
the time the elections were on on TV it
started dropping talent so people got it
out or they said who they were looking
at stormy Daniels right I didn't see
anything about who they were checking
out there was wave on the day of
midterms yeah so about 4 or 5 a.m. that
day so like all those paper ballots were
a little sticky so and so as yes very
good I missed it for a second that I had
to stop and come back to it it's like
they're recounting the Florida elections
was all the jerking off it's women
increased by nearly 21% on Election Day
Wow women looking at porn what type of
show do you think it was like violent
like doing violent things to men porn we
just started this I guess what the
somebody called and said why is all porn
anal these days you watch it you say
we're like why is this guy said it and
we looked at the most common things that
people search for and it's pretty weird
the number 4 thing out of all the topics
is hentai which is Japanese animated
porn that's so we that's beyond us
nothing for me that's but that's beyond
like look at big butts
you know tits it's like cartoon sex like
that it gets dark
oh yeah nerd alert that's a billion
wicked thoughts where they look at all
the the porn hubs server and what the
most you ever get one that comes up and
you're like god damn yeah it's yeah but
like even beyond like that's some
vanilla [ __ ] not really I'm like what
the [ __ ] but he gets decide videos you
might like fart fart breathers like guys
you just like really want to get their
face in there just like inhale a faraway
- plastic - oh yeah it's real deal [ __ ]
anything that really like like is just
that the amount of like incest porn
there is being so much just titles don't
let throw it for your Lube like one it's
like stepmom [ __ ] son and I come mom
mom's a caring mother sometimes I like
that's not a real mom son yeah a
derivative of mom like mom milf whatever
that's the I think the third most mommy
taught something else I click on it
that's it that's good man doctor doctor
what's your last name winter winter
winter oh wow yeah that's a cool name
working thank you I do oh yeah they can
find me let's see my Instagram is that
Ashley G winter you want to practice
it's in Portland I'm in Portland
no I live important I live in Portland
yeah we commute to each other oh wow
yeah yeah I work that out right now
release a full release
yeah the four release pod calm or the
for release pod and Instagram and we do
episodes every Thursday all that and
then I'll be performing at the house of
comedy in Phoenix Arizona this weekend
five shows Friday through Sunday that's
Rick Bronson script I say I reckon yeah
he's a good dude I got an hour special
on Amazon - called the not the fall it's
called negative reinforcement nice man
thank yes coming in alright guys that's
the fun kid we're out yeah